LOOK AHEAD RIGHT HERE RIGHT NOW
ON "SUNDAY MORNING FUTURES."
>> AND CHINA COMING UNDER
INTENSE SCRUTINY THIS WEEK
AMID MOUNTING CRITICISM OF ITS
EARLY RESPONSE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK.
MY FIRST GUEST THIS MORNING WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST TO SEE THE
PANDEMIC COMING.
WE WANT TO BRING IN WHITE HOUSE
TRADE ADVISOR PETER NAVARRO.
PETER IT’S GREAT TO SEE YOU THIS
MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING MARIA.
MARIA: THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
EARLY WARNINGS AND GREAT WORK ON
THIS , PETER I KNOW YOU’VE BEEN
BUSY WITH THE SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES BUT I WANT TO TALK FIRST
ABOUT CHINA AND WHAT WE’RE
LEARNING THIS MORNING.
PRO-DEMOCRACY ACTIVISTS WERE
ARRESTED OVER THE WEEKEND, PETER
, A FURTHER CRACKDOWN ON
HONG KONG, AS CHINA CONTINUES TO
EXERT AUTHOR THEIR YANKEESISM
THROUGHOUT HONG KONG, YOUR
REACTION TO WHAT WE SAW THIS
WEEKEND AND BROADLY
SPEAKING, WHAT CHINA HAS DONE IN
THE MIDST OF THIS CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC.
>> MARIA, MY FOCUS HERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS MADE SURE THAT
THE PEOPLE OF AMERICA ARE SAFE
FROM THIS VIRUS IN GETTING
THINGS LIKE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT, MASKS, VENTILATORS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT BUT HERE IS
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT CHINA.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT CHINA
DID OVER THE COURSE OF THIS
THING, THEY DID FOUR THINGS
THAT LED TO THE DEATHS OF MANY
PEOPLE WORLDWIDE, AND FIRST OF
ALL, THE VIRUS WAS SPUN IN CHINA
SECOND OF ALL THEY HID THE VIRUS
BEHIND THE SHIELD OF THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
THE THIRD THING THEY DID WAS
BASICALLY HORDEE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND NOW
THEY ARE PROFIT EARRING FROM IT
AND IF YOU WALK THROUGH THAT,
YOU WERE ONE OF THE FIRST IN THE
MEDIA TO RAISE THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER THAT P 4 LAB WAS
INVOLVED.
THAT’S AN INTERESTING ISSUE.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT THE GROUND
ZERO FOR THIS VIRUS WAS WITHIN A
FEW MILES OF THAT LAB, IF YOU
SIMPLY DO A RAZOR APPROACH IT’S
THE SIMPLEST EXPLANATION IS THE
PROBABLY THE MOST LIKELY I
THINK IT’S INCUMBENT ON CHINA TO
PROVE THAT IT WASN’T THAT LAB SO
THAT’S NUMBER ONE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, WE KNOW THAT FOR A
CRITICAL SIX-WEEK PERIOD OF TIME
, CHINA USED ITS INFLUENCE
AT THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
TO HIDE THE VIRUS FROM THE WORLD
THIS WAS A TIME WHERE THAT VIRUS
COULD HAVE BEEN CONTAINED IN
WUHAN, INSTEAD 5 MILLION
CHINESE PEOPLE WENT OUT FROM
WUHAN AND PROPAGATED THE VIRUS
AROUND THE WORLD AND THAT WAS A
CRITICAL TIME, SO THAT WAS THAT
AND THEN, HERE IS WHAT I THINK
SHOULD BE VERY DISTURBING TO
EVERY AMERICAN.
DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME, THAT
SIX-WEEK INTERVAL WHEN THEY WERE
HIDING THIS VIRUS FROM THE WORLD
, CHINA WENT FROM A NET
EXPORTER OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THEY ARE
THE LARGEST PRODUCER OF THAT IN
THE WORLD TO A LARGE NET IMPORT
ER.
THEY BASICALLY WENT AROUND AND
VACUUMED UP VIRTUALLY ALL OF THE
PPE AROUND THE WORLD
INCLUDING A LOT FROM THIS
COUNTRY, WHICH WAS FOR
HUMANITARIAN REASONS
SHARING OUR PPE WITH THEM, AND
WHAT THAT DID WAS LEAVE PEOPLE
IN NEW YORK, MILAN, AND
EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN DEFENSE
LESS WHEN IT CAME TIME TO HAVE
THAT PPE.
NOW WHAT’S HAPPENING TODAY WHICH
IS EQUALLY ALARMING IS CHINA IS
SITTING ON
THAT HORDE OF PPE WHERE IT
CORNERED THE MARKET AND IT’S
PROFITEERING.
I HAVE CASES COMING ACROSS MY
DESK WHERE $0.50 MASKS MADE IN
CHINA ARE BEING SOLD TO HOSPITAL
S HERE IN AMERICA FOR AS
MUCH AS $8.
MARIA: UNBELIEVABLE.
I REMEMBER A MONTH AGO WHEN I
GOT A CALL FROM A LEADING
HOSPITAL EXECUTIVE WHO SAID TO
ME, MARIA, THERE ARE MASKS AND
GLOVES, PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
THAT WERE ON A SHIP COMING FROM
CHINA TO AMERICA, THOSE SHIPS
WERE TOLD TO TURN AROUND, THAT
CHINA SAID WE’RE NOT KEEPING ANY
COMMITMENTS THAT WE HAD TO
EXPORT ANY OF THIS STUFF.
CHINA WANTS IT AND THEN AS YOU
POINT OUT, THEY CORNERED THE
MARKET, THEY ALREADY
PRODUCED HALF OF THE WORLD’S
CAPACITY OF THIS PROTECTIVE GEAR
, AND YET THEY WERE IN THE
MARKET BUYING 2 BILLION
ADDITIONAL MASKS IN JANUARY.
PETER I DON’T UNDERSTAND WHAT’S
GOING ON HERE.
THIS IS EVEN MORE SINISTER THAN
WE THOUGHT.
FIRST THIS VIRUS ESCAPES,
SICKENS THE WORLD AND THEN THEY
TURN AROUND AND TRY TO MAKE IT
HARDER FOR THE UNITED STATES TO
GET THE PRODUCTS THEY NEED?
>> I THINK THAT CHINA RIGHT NOW
, AFTER DOING THOSE FOUR
ACTIONS WHICH EFFECTIVELY HAVE
KILLED TO DATE 39,000 AMERICANS
AND 160,000 PEOPLE WORLDWIDE MAY
ATTEMPT TO USE
THIS CRISIS NOW TO ADVANCE THEIR
OWN AGENDA WORLDWIDE, SO MY
FOCUS RIGHT NOW IS JUST TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE HAVE EVERYTHING THEY
NEED HERE, BUT I THINK --
MARIA: AND I WANT TO GET TO THAT
BECAUSE I KNOW YOUR WORKING WITH
HONEYWELL, YOU’RE WORKING WITH A
NUMBER OF COMPANIES AND DOING A
LOT EVEN IN NEW YORK WITH MAYOR
DEBLASIO.
WE’LL GET TO THAT AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE AUDIENCE
UNDERSTANDS WHAT’S HAPPENING BUT
LET ME GET YOUR TAKE ON THIS.
IF WE SEE ALL OF THIS BAD
BEHAVIOR CONTINUING, FROM CHINA,
ARE GLOBAL COMPANIES GOING TO
RECOGNIZE IF THEY WANT TO SELL
TO 1.4 BILLION PEOPLE IN CHINA,
THEY NEED TO DO SO WITH THEIR
EYES OPEN.
YOU’VE GOT INTELLECTUAL THEFT
CONTINUING, YOU’VE GOT 1 MILLION
RIGHT NOW IN CAMPS, IN CHINA,
YOU’VE GOT ALL OF THIS BEHAVIOR
GOING ON IN CHINA, SO I SPOKE
WITH SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO ON FRIDAY AND I ASKED THE
SECRETARY, IS THE WORLD
GETTING IT?
IS EUROPE, FOR EXAMPLE, OUR
FRIENDS IN EUROPE SAYING TO THE
SECRETARY LOOK, MAYBE WE WILL
UNWIND THAT HUAWEI TECHNOLOGY.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT THE
SECRETARY SAID IN REGARDS TO
EUROPEAN FRIENDS AND GLOBAL
BUSINESSES AND WHETHER OR  NOT
THERE’S A NEW THINKING AROUND
CHINA.
HERE IS WHAT THE SECRETARY TOLD
ME FRIDAY.
>> I AM VERY CONFIDENT THAT AT
THIS MOMENT WHERE THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY FAILED TO BE
TRANSPARENT AND OPEN AND HANDLE
DATA IN AN APPROPRIATE WAY WILL
CAUSE MANY MANY COUNTRIES TO
RETHINK WHAT THEY WERE DOING
WITH RESPECT TO THEIR TELECOM
ARCHITECTURE AND WHEN HUAWEI
COMES KNOCKING TO SELL THEM
EQUIPMENT AND HARDWARE THEY WILL
HAVE A DIFFERENT PRISM THROUGH
WHICH TO VIEW THAT DECISION.
I’M HOPEFUL THAT’S THE CASE.
THIS IS ABOUT SECURITY AND
MAKING SURE THAT U.S. DATA,
AMERICAN’S DATA THAT TRAVELS
ACROSS THEIR NETWORKS IS SAFE
AND SECURE AS WELL.
MARIA: WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO
COMPANIES THAT ARE ALIGNED WITH
CHINA?
>> TWO THINGS.
I THINK THIS HAS BEEN A REAL
MOMENT FOR BUSINESS LEADERS ALL
ACROSS AMERICA TO SEE THE
POLITICAL RISK
ASSOCIATED WITH OPERATIONS
INSIDE OF CHINA.
YOU KNOW THIS MARIA YOU’VE BEEN
AROUND A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE
THEY CAN DEAL WITH COMMERCIAL
RISKS AND POLITICAL RISK, IT’S
ENORMOUSLY DIFFICULT TO DEAL AND
NOW WE’VE RIPPED THE BAND AID
OFF, THE POLITICAL RISK
CONNECTED TO THAT AND SECOND THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT HAS
A RESPONSIBILITY TO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THE SUPPLY CHAIN FOR
THE PRODUCTS THAT MATTER,
FOR AMERICAN NATIONAL SECURITY
AND KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE ARE NO
LONGER DEPENDENT ON ANY SINGLE
COUNTRY, AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO GET THAT RIGHT
MARIA: SO WITH PETER NAVARRO
THIS MORNING, PETER YOU’RE THE
POINT MAN ON THE SUPPLY
CHAIN.
WE’RE GOING TO TAKE A BREAK AND
WHEN WE COME BACK FROM THE BREAK
I’LL ASK YOU WHAT YOU’RE DOING
RIGHT NOW BUT BROADLY SPEAKING
BEFORE WE GO TO BREAK REAL QUICK
, DO YOU SEE A DIFFERENT
SHIFT IN THINKING FROM COMPANIES
TRYING TO MOVE THE SUPPLY CHAIN
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES AS A
RESULT OF CHINA’S BEHAVIOR?
>> I SEE SINCE PRESIDENT DONALD
J. TRUMP TOOK OFFICE THE ONLY
PRESIDENT WHOSE EVER STOOD UP TO
CHINA SINCE HE TOOK OFFICE,
WE’VE SEEN A SHIFT OF THAT
SUPPLY CHAIN BECAUSE OF THE
KINDS OF RISK THAT SECRETARY
POMPEO SO ELOQUENTLY JUST STATED